hello everyone and welcome to a most
incredible game app from the video world
team championship 2022 it is uh the
legend himself vasel ivanchuk versus
Jordan Farm Forest one of Magnus
carlsen's Protege and uh definitely a
strong player to 26.99 the rating the
so-called Hans Neiman rating and this
game is like uh I mean it's like
watching the old Vaseline manchuk like
uh someone who was feared by every
player in the world who could just
demolish everyone in in a most
unimaginable style uh and the new vessel
who sometimes uh I I guess uh you know
misses that his uh piece is attacked so
it's a it's truly an incredible game and
I'm sure you guys are going to enjoy it
let's dive straight into it so yeah
vassal with the white pieces opens with
Ponte D4 we have D5 by Jordan uh C4 uh
going for the Queen's Gambit and the E6
declining the Gambit with Knight to the
C3 and C5 the tarash defense is on the
board see captures on d5e characters and
now Knight to F3 the two knights
variation followed by the three Knights
variation E3 and pawn to A6 now and here
usually you will see Bishop D2 uh this
is the by far the most popular move D
capitals and C5 and G3 are also very
popular but here we have B3 it's a it's
not a very often uh played move uh but
it's it has been played by some very
strong Grand Masters like Vladimir
kramnik played at ponkarat of play the
avoider shark played it uh so yeah it is
not unexplored territory we have Knights
the C6 Bishop to B2 and now Bishop to G4
pinning that Knight with Bishop to EQ in
here at Jordan trades the bishop for
Knight captures captures and now C
captures on D4 we have e cap for sun D4
and now Bishop to B4 so still all known
territory we have Castles by both
players castles castles Knight the a for
now uh idea being
I've also wants to bring the knights the
C5 with the Knight on C5 uh will be an
amazing piece maybe later on you can
shift it to D3 and the E5 and you never
really care about Bishop capturing that
Knight if Bishop captures Knight Q uh
capture with the d-pawn and you open up
your uh dark Square Bishop along this
diagonal which will be an incredible
piece so here there is one game where
Bishop the D6 was played but here we
have rooked the E8 by Jordan and it is
now as of move at 13 that we have a
completely new game so let's see what
happens here in Knights the C5 of course
uh we have B6 chasing away the Knight
and knights the D3 and now Bishop to D6
as the bishop was attacked and you
really like your Bishop here Rook to C1
putting the Rook on a nice open C file
uh Jordan does the same and now Rook the
E1 and both players nicely develop the
Rooks and open files Knight the E4 as uh
Jordan has full control over D4 Square
so he gets his Knight to the E4 and now
Rook the E2 nice calm rock lift
preparing Rook to C2 to double up on the
C file we have Queen to D7 and Rook e to
C2 we have 9 back to F6 now and pawn to
G3 still nothing happening just uh
putting pieces on optimal squares G3
Bishop will be put to G2 uh we have G6
by order and also creating some breeding
room for the king Bishop to G2 and now
Rook the C7 also with an idea maybe
doubling up on the C file maybe Queen to
C8 will be an idea
and uh vasel plays Queen to F1 now
X-Ring that A6 spawn but also having now
control over the H3 Square he's
preparing Bishop to H3 so Jordan has to
figure out how to deal with both of
these ideas uh idea he could play Rook
D7 or queen to C8 those are the popular
options he goes for Rook the E7 and okay
now Bishop to H3 we have Queen to E8
sorry that's not an E8 Queen T8 uh and
now Knight to E5 a beautiful Square for
the Knight and you can't really capture
it if you capture them Pawn captures
you're gonna be losing material here uh
it doesn't matter if you capture because
there's all this pressure on the C file
if Bishop captures and E5 just look
captures on C7 and now it really doesn't
matter Rook captures Rook captures
You're Gonna Play Bishop captures and it
looks like something is happening but
Bishop captures an F6 every uh exchange
variation you can think of here Ends by
white is simply winning so Jordan plays
Knight back to B8 and this is by far the
best idea yeah offers a trade of Rooks
on the openc file and here okay the
interesting thing is uh instead of
Knight captures any five I'm sure you
guys are wondering what happens if
Bishop captures on E5 well this line is
so complicated uh that I absolutely must
show it Bishop captures an E5 D captures
on E5 and okay Knight to E4 uh Bishop to
A3 attacks the rook and now the only way
for black to save The Rook as the
Bishops here are absolute monsters is to
play
after this bishop they remove Rook
captures on E5 Now Pawn the F4 now
you're gonna play Rook the H5 now Bishop
to G4 and now Rook to H6 so you can save
The Rook but yeah I mean what is The
Rook doing there and now look at this
queen captures an A6 Knight captures and
G3 and there's no better way to play
this because Black's position is just
terrible I mean the Rooks here are
absolute Monsters the Bishops uh even
greater Monsters the queen controls the
entire board basically so this is your
only option Knight captures on G3 H
capture sng3 and now not the immediate
Queen to E3 check but rather first
Knight to D4 and here black could even
win if white accepts The Rook if white
accepts The Rook then you actually can
win Queen to E3 with check and now after
King to G2 you have a very nice
checkmating sequence Queen T for
checking G1 Rook to H1 with checking to
F2 and now you just go for checkmate
Rook HD checking to G1 or F1 doesn't
really matter because Queen to H1 will
be Checkmate however uh after this
Knight the D4 move in this absolutely
crazy line there is the very simple Rook
to F2 and now there is nothing left for
black uh you no longer have to worry
about Queen to E3 you no longer have to
worry about this Rook The Rook is
defended and after something like Rook
captures Bishop captures and queen to e
for threatening Rook the H1 Checkmate uh
White can follow up with Bishop to H3
brilliant stuff now preparing Bishop to
G2
if the bishop lands on G2 you never have
to worry about this queen and if Rook
captures an H3 of course Queen to C8
with check picks up the Rook on H3 and
so that's pretty much it King G7 Queen
captures here and even after Knight they
eat you with check let's say King H2
okay you will pick up the bishop here
but now F5 and the position is just
winning for white for example captures
captures you either trade queens and
white has a winning end game you have to
worry about Queen captures and F7 you
have to worry about Queen to G5 check
winning the Knight and C1 so uh
absolutely winning for white but this is
what you have to calculate when uh when
you're playing uh Vaseline he plays
Knight the E5 so okay Knight's the B8 uh
and now we have Bishop to A3 uh really
making that that Bishop pair work uh and
now comes Queen to d8 here the best for
yeah Jordan was just trading all of the
Rooks on the C file let's say capris
captures and it's still not a good
position for black let's say queen C1
puts pressure on the bush them but you
are at least fighting after Queen to d8
we reach the position from the thumbnail
if I will use this for the thumbnail and
that is the move that a vasel played so
not only did you have to calculate all
of that when vassal put the Knight on E5
but now you have to calculate what
happens after Knight to D7 and
interestingly whilst they didn't just
calculate all of the things that
happened when the knights the E5 uh is
played but he also had to go even
further and imagine that the Knight will
actually reach the D7 square and now the
problem is the Rooks are disconnected
and uh well just there are so many
threats here one of them being just
Knight captures and F6 that's a free
Knight there so you can't uh you can't
just leave the Knight on F6 and what
happens if Knight captures on D7
uh your Rooks are again disconnected and
now Rook captures on C7 simply wins uh
material for white Bishop captures on C7
Bishop captures an E7 Queen captures
through captors and C7 and you are up in
exchange without uh a good way to play
this so the White Queen will come into
the game and this is completely crushing
uh capturing with the other Knight isn't
all that better because it it's pretty
much the exact same position you're just
going to capture here Rook uh Bishop
captures Bishop capture 77 Queen
captures Rook captures on C7 and it's
the exact same position so here Jordan
played Rook captures Rook e captures on
D7 and now just Bishop captures and D6
and what's what's the point here it
doesn't seem like Russell is the winning
back material but he is and uh well with
interest so real characters on C2 Rook
captures Rook captures and D6 and
finally you see the idea behind the
vassal's Knight the E5 move that is
broke the C8 and vasel now wins Jordan's
Queen there is nothing better than Queen
captures on C8 Bishop captures on C8 and
now Knight to C6 so Jordan will not of
course resign he still has a rook in the
Knight for the queen uh we have Queen
captures on A6 now uh also Russell has a
two to one advantage on the queen side
he will just push those pawns and create
a past Pawn Knight captures on D4 and
now King the G2 with King to G7 and pawn
to B4 of course vasel knows how to push
those pawns Knight to the C2 and now
Queen to A4 putting pressure on the
knight uh you have to put your pieces on
optimal squares before you really start
pushing those pawns Knight day one with
Chuck King F1 Knight to F3 going for the
H2 Pawn but just Queen to D1 not worried
about the the pawn because now if you
capture just King G2 and the Knight well
the Knight can go to G4 but it's not
much just Bishop captures and queen
captures uh will win you the piece so
after Queen to D1 Knight to E5 and now
Queen to D4 putting pressure on the
Knight we have Knight to F3 attacking
the queen again
and here vassel should just calmly
played Queen to C3 he should keep the
tension here not allow the knights to
move not allow the king to move put
pressure on the Knight on F3 and now uh
prepare A4 A5 that's how you should play
this however he played Queen to F4 which
is also very nice because it attacks the
rook and the Knight on F3 and he really
wants the force traits here but he
missed one very tricky move from Jordan
and I will ask you to pause the video
here and try to find this tricky move
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the idea
that the a great vassal mist and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is night the E4 at defense his
rook and now Jordan says uh feel free to
capture my knight on F3 because if you
capture it Knights the D2 check picks up
the queen and then I'm just completely
winning character Knight Queen captures
King captures and you have a rook
against a bishop so completely winning
so 94 King to G2 by vasel and now
Knights the E1 with check King to F1 and
not Knight to D3 so he manages to save
all of his pieces Quinta E3 and now
Knight D captures on F2 grabbing that
pawn and now uh once The Rook comes to
C6 attacks the bishop prepares Rook to
C1 with check it will be very very
difficult uh for vassal to defend so
Queen to D4 with check King the G8 and
now comes Pawn to A4 and this is exactly
what we talked about vasel wants to
create a past Pawn here with A5 but
first he had to play B5 he had to
prevent Rook to C6 because that's such a
powerful idea for black
but okay Rook up Ponte for Rook to C6
and now Bishop to A6 getting the bishop
out of Harm's Way also you might be able
to use the bishop to defend Rook to C1
with check King to G2 and now Knight to
G4 and here there was still a way for
evassel to play and even win this with
H3 his position is still winning for
example Rook to C2 checking G1 Rook to
C1 check Bishop to F1 and now not much
to be done here if Knight TF2 you will
play Queen Queen captures on B6 and
everything is nicely defended there's
not much you can do here if Knight
captures on H3 just play King G2 not
much is happening and you start
advancing your pawns however after
Knight the G4 vasel played Bishop to D3
and he missed uh such a painful move uh
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find what also missed in this
position and win the game for Jordan
while I give you a couple of seconds
all right
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh incredible uh will uh paralyzing move
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Rook to D1 this is
how vassal ruins his Immortal uh but
what are you gonna do yeah and uh well
but a nice nicely done by Jordan of
course by uh not resigning by sticking
in the game and by finding the absolute
strongest move for the rest of the game
uh so now the bishop cannot move and the
simple idea of Bishop capterson E4 which
was the plan just trading off pieces it
doesn't really work anymore so now vasel
starts pushing A5 now comes Rook to D2
with check King to G1 and now Knight E
to F2 here you should go for Rook to D1
check and first trade off a pair of
Pawns here but Knight eat the F2 was
played and now again uh he gives the
vasel a chance to fight evasso should
give up the bishop and just go for the
two pass pawns Knight captures on D3 H3
Knight G2 E5 and now Queen 38 with
checking G7 Queen captures on D5 and you
push those pawns and maybe good things
will happen but here Queen captures on
D5 was played and this is much much
different because now Knight the H3
check vessel misses everything now King
the H2 King to H1 will be met with Rook
captures an H2 Checkmate and the King to
F1 will of course be met with Knight the
E3 check winning back the White Queen so
absolutely stunning King the E1 Rook the
D1 Chuck King E2 now Knight captures on
D5 King capture Sunday one Knight to F2
with check trading off the Knight for
Bishop as well uh King D2 Knight
captures on D3 and he was in this
position unmove 40 54 uh that Vaseline
manchuk resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here King
captures on D3 Knight captures on B4
with check King C4 and B captures and A5
will be played where you're have a a
full night and he would have four points
to two of course this is completely
winning for him so absolute absolutely
stunning game uh the entire game like
the idea of just bringing the knights
the uh sorry I believe in the middle of
the video I said knife gameplay
E5 calculating this and then calculating
this and then calculating this and then
just finding all of this and just
trading it down into a completely
winning end game and then blundering not
once not twice but three times uh well
that's that's just for you you uh you
know we love it for that and we hate it
for that we love it when it doesn't
happen to us but we love it when it
happens to our opponents uh so yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it once again a big congratulations to
Jordan uh for withstanding such uh such
a brilliant attack by wasil that's also
a sign of a true great player uh because
it's not all about attacking you also
have to know how to defend perfectly uh
so yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed
this I would like to thank Carmen
polifranio revision reptiles YouTube
Austin wheeler Ahmed Yousef and
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
affiliate world team championship and
everything else that's happening in the
Chess World and hopefully we get more
spectacular games such as this one uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day